you already reel a fish in Willow yeah
been a while huh yeah we'll
see well today Timber and Willow Willow
mostly they've both been asking to go
fishing so see if we can just pull one
winter King
in Kings they got good fat content and
especially this time of year when we
don't get Sunshine Salmons are vitamin
D oh yeah I'm starting to Mark
Bait Timber are you okay to drive for a
minute yeah you drive and I'll throw out
the the sneaker pole out the back here
see if we can't get these girls hooked
on a king cross our
fingers I'm Cole Sturgis I live in Thorn
Bay Alaska on Prince of wals Island in
Southeast
Alaska my family and I live in our
two-story house that floats in the ocean
my oldest is Timber my middle daughter
is Willow and we have a little
2-year-old that's a cedar and when
you're a logger you tend to name your
kids after
trees coming from Montana I've never
been in the ocean really until I found a
job cutting
Timber and didn't take us long at all to
figure out we're heading
north for me everything in Thorn Bay is
unique the peace the quiet of it there's
no rat race
here it's a
rainforest things grow here like I've
never
seen it's a magical
place
we try to sustain on what the ocean
gives us and this land around here
provides us if we don't stay on top of
the food
chain we
start to be proficient up here you have
to be
stubborn I'm kind of a jack of all
trades and a master of none I don't know
much but I know a lot you
know nice and easy there you go we're
under one good
job it's a big Advantage teaching your
children how to drive I can be man in
the PO and Timber knows to take us on
Course May one night we're just waiting
now good job
girls really makes a person
proud that your children are
that cool yeah good job coming in let's
see if there's a king in here I like
that this is the greatest thing I've
been gifted with to raise my girls and
help them and teach
them
what wrong
Willow Timber get cold yeah all right
we'll Circle back towards the house I'll
just go out and check tomorrow maybe
we'll get some
[Music]
fish